anything why is it not pain your stomach
yet
[Music]
hey what's going on everybody for first
we feast I'm Sean Evans and you're
watching hot ones it's the show of hot
questions and even hotter wings and
today we're joined by Noel Gallagher
he's a rock and roll legend formerly of
the band Oasis currently with Noel
Gallagher's high flying birds this is
the place is the newest single and EP go
check those out but in the meantime no
Gallagher welcome to the show thank you
very much
are you a spicy food guy not
particularly I've got a raging hangover
because I had a show last night we
didn't get in till all hours of the
morning so I'm not sure how this is
gonna go but I've got beer and milk and
water and I'm and I've got a lot of
enthusiasm
[Music]
all right whoa there you go see I said
that was [ __ ] jumped out of his hand
still live lost the first wing for the
first time my seasons in my man down all
right so this first ones the classic
be careful they're slippery all right so
you're someone who fully understands the
power of youth culture from seeing the
outlet it provided your own rebellious
Ness to the effect that your music has
had on younger fans when you look at
youth culture today do you say like oh
well Kanye is there Sex Pistols and
Nikes are there Doc Martens or do you
have some sort of worry that the kids
might be lost my youngest is either 9 or
7 but definitely not 8 it could be 8 and
he's the law in our house he is the law
he's the most switched-on nine-year-old
ever but there's good stuff there for
sure we've got move a grind thing going
on in England that would be like the new
punk rock or something my kids are into
a lot and I wouldn't I wouldn't probably
have no I said if it wasn't for my
children are you proud that you know
that with grime UK can have hip hop that
is distinctly English rather than some
sort of copy of American rap so yeah I
mean when when the hip hop first came to
England in the in the 80s and then of
British hip hop I side it was a bit kind
of like that but these guys are doing
the grime stuff just on Sue's capture
and people like that you know they're
talking in their own language and
they've got huge huge records and
headlining Glastonbury it's infallible
they've done it all on their own terms
by speaking their own language there's
no compromise to it you know it's all
comes from the streets and longmate rain
I can see even by the labels on the
sauces it's about to start getting but
there's one with a [ __ ] nuclear bomb
on it yeah so one of my favorite Knoll
Gallagher isms is the one about you
being uninterested in everything besides
music family and football yeah what's
the biggest difference between being a
Manchester City fan now versus when you
were growing up like do you think your
kids take for granted that they're now
from your ship powerhouse in England we
don't you know you you you a team
chooses you and that's it forever
in America you you guys can't attend to
you know flip flop and do whatever you
want the main differences were winning
trophies now we're living in the
greatest time zone are you still into
the NFL I haven't met many Brits that
are into that variety of well I die I do
like it once I'd worked out the rules I
just loved watching it because it looked
fantastic and all the players look like
Space Age and all up I didn't know how
it worked and then once I'd worked out
that it's something on him in it he's
got there's three goals to get the ball
ten yards and if you don't do that on
the fourth one you've got hidden launch
over the pitch I was like I hang on a
minute okay I get this now and if I'm
ever tour in America enjoying the
football season there's nothing better
than light there on a Sunday kind of
lying in a nondescript hotel room in
[ __ ] Buffalo
hungover what's in three games of
American football while eating [ __ ]
much potatoes and for breakfast there's
nothing there's nothing better than that
[Music]
pineapple habanero and we're not
crossing well necessary genres here I
think that that's up to you to decide
you know what if I think we are then you
know ice like the idiot who first place
the pineapple on a pizza but you heard
it here you heard it here at hot ones
it's not right it's not right so in a
2011 Rolling Stone profile legendary
record producer David Sardi described
you as one of the best songwriters of
your generation and I imagine that some
they come naturally to you and others
maybe they take years what's the longest
length of time you've ever had from when
you started a song to when you finally
finished it this is the place took four
years from start to finish
now obviously not in the studio for
eight hours a day for four years I mean
that would be insane kind of coming back
to it seemed you get it better on
barabar but usually the songs that live
longest in the public consciousness are
the ones that just fall out of the sky
in comedy there's this cliche that a
fact comedian is maybe less funny once
they lose the weight even the premise of
the his phony is there a rock star
corollary to that like are there
challenges in writing when you've
experienced success that maybe you
didn't have when you were just a boy in
Manchester without a pot to piss in well
Fame and success they can take you
pretty hard
for instance Amy Winehouse never
recovered from Fame god bless her you
know she just wasn't she wasn't equipped
to deal with it when I was writing in
the early days of Oasis I was in the
same circumstances as the audience we
haven't made any money we're still
wearing the same clothes as the audience
and there's that magic period for maybe
a year or six months where you're
writing for the people that are coming
to your gigs and then they'll become a
period where the big checks arrive and
you go right well I'm getting a [ __ ]
chimp okay I don't give a [ __ ] where
anyone says and I'm getting a top-up and
I'm getting a [ __ ] car and guess what
I can't even [ __ ] Drive so then you
start to become is slightly removed from
your audience and then you've got to
rethink what you do almost but I think
for me personally ads are trying to
focus on the universal truths of life
and everybody falls in love everybody
falls out of love everybody's had their
heart broken everybody loses the hair
[Music]
so yeah but there is there is the magic
period that was the magic period that
made all a sustainable I found it to be
like 99% of the people that came to the
cakes lost Caliente now what's in this
my [ __ ] raspberries is one there is
some apricot in this shake I'm telling
you by that you mean apricot yes apricot
there's apricot in this there's some
fruit in this that's nice actually
you're into that one yeah that's good
so know you've been a touring musician
for 30 years and then that time made
more than your fair share of headlines
so here on this wing we just want to set
the record straight on some curious
fabled Knoll Gallagher internet rumors
okay
is there any truth to the rumor that you
were sued by coca-cola and had to pay a
half million dollars in damages for
allegedly lifting a jingle melody you
say lifting we say stole
I do believe that some money had to
change hands with coca-cola they were
broke at the time I did steal quite a
chunk of a song unintentionally I might
add it was just kind of in there there's
a funny old phone call you know yeah we
got a caller on the line
what we've got cobbler coca-cola I'm
gonna sue you it's like me coca-cola
[ __ ] wankers why and yeah I don't
know I don't know if it's a familiar
thanks probably more than half a million
dollars I tuned most about more than
that
yeah yes but yeah our moaning quit is it
true that you refused to make music for
the Trainspotting soundtrack because you
thought it would be a boring movie about
people spotting trains
nobody told me why was it not called
[ __ ] heroin had an arrow in [ __ ] I
don't build why did it not say in the
tile I'd never heard of Irving Welsh I'm
not very intellectual I don't read books
and that's that's phase five about
[ __ ] spotting trains no you're all
right mate and little did I know you
know what going to one of the great
British films of all time is it true
that the local council set up a bench
outside your primrose homes you know the
fans that were camping out outside yeah
and they put a rubbish bin cement is run
into the street because it was a lot a
lot of kids outside my house in the 90s
it could work in your favour if you got
up and you had a hangover you could go
out to the front gate and people that
get all excited and you just say you
couldn't go to the shop for us and get
some cigarettes cause you know be like
can I get an autograph like if you go to
the shop and get me 60 Benson & Hedges
get some I'm so Ressler papers on the
news platform and then finally is it
true that you once spent a hundred and
ten thousand pounds on our vintage
Jaguar from your birth year that you
didn't even know how to drive
never stop never driven it you still got
it I've never driven it it's a beautiful
car
it's black convertible 1967 mark -
Jaguar Adobe now this came about by I
was made aware of this firm in England
the find vintage Sassy's and then put
like modern cars in them
[ __ ] and I went to see them and they
said it would take about two years to
build another easily will it pass my
testing to use easily two years later in
my house and a filling the cattle op
flatbed truck pulled up when I was a car
on the back of a hot [ __ ] car I want
to get me one of those cars one day when
I passed my test some guy come up with
the clipboard and he rang the bell and
he said I've got car I'd have to deliver
it for mr. Gallagher now so and it kind
of dawned on me that I'd forgotten to
take the driving lessons I was getting
high instead I mean others but I still
got the car and my kids are kind of
vying for who's gonna get out there
competing a little bit yeah who's gonna
get my daughter thinks she's gonna get
up with you got it see I [ __ ] hate
horseradish mmm really not even sure
what it is I love it I don't know why I
wanna cost you lover you've made a
[ __ ] career out of it do you like
wasabi or anything like that
not really that stuff you're getting
sushi restaurants the green stuff right
ah it's like smelling salts yeah there's
something about I start to get funny no
no mm-hmm
so they say milk is the best for spicy
food I've seen not a man versus food wow
you came prepared today no the funny
thing is all right I was obsessed with
man versus food shout out adam richman
he is a friend of mine is he really yeah
if I can do it the new guy that does it
it's not great okay no offense to
everyone but I'm yeah my wife would walk
into I'll be sitting there kind of
[ __ ] watching TV's like wait what's
in this [ __ ] for and I was like a size
house [ __ ] burger he's gonna eat it
and then you're gonna get t-shirt yeah
he's gonna get a t-shirt you're gonna
get a picture on the wall in [ __ ]
some place in the middle of nowhere
I know we have recurring segments on our
show called explain that Graham where do
a deep dive on our guess Instagram pull
interesting pictures that need more
context roll backs but I think you'll be
in the clear this is from that Net Worth
concert in front of 125,000 people we
were talking about this the other day
this is 1997 if you think of all the
technology that was available then for
banners to do gigs that size like you to
have done the Zoo TV tour and Nala we've
got a little [ __ ] shitty piece of
cloth as a backdrop which just says
Oasis on it and we thought that'd be
enough I do a lot back in it fondly and
that time funnily enough when we did the
Oasis documentary a few years ago
there's a still of the crowd with
playing and 125 thousand people and the
best thing about the photograph is not
one a single person has got telephone so
everyone's in the moment with the band
you know the 250,000 people came to that
weekend and there was one arrest in this
day and age there would be extreme
violence and extreme selfie taking and
like a stream streaming you know I mean
so I'm they are good good good memory of
a different time
[Music]
byah yep fire fire [ __ ] all right now
it's getting [ __ ] dirty in it yeah
it's getting dark now so you do you eat
these for a living yep that's what I do
for a living so that's my job to cover
the hair well no well yeah the hair left
before the wings believe it or not okay
I've heard you said that you're
fascinated by Kanye West and you guys
are obviously very different in a lot of
ways but you do have this unique
distinction of being two guys who've
been click baited to the point of not
knowing what's fact or what's fiction
what interests you about him and
particularly the interviews that he does
well I'd heard his music the first thing
I as well his interviews I just don't
give a [ __ ] he was doing the sin if he
wants and I was like what asks of steels
for this he didn't give a [ __ ] and then
I checked eyes music and I really liked
his music
what Skynyrd was like revolutionary a
sponsor did you want him to hop on a
high flying bird song no we are well
what we you're writing this tune for an
album and we were pretending we were
gonna write it for Kenya and then it
came out as like [ __ ] him [ __ ] him
[ __ ] making me seven hundred million
dollars next year I'll put out make
seven grand
Mike I'm gonna go for it okay now all
right [ __ ] it is a key I can assume that
the ghost Reaper come on man
Marco I still the worst things ever to
the ghost and the Grim Reaper in one
condiment straight to the face walk
around mm-hmm right if you [ __ ] up you
tell me we're gonna [ __ ] him sometime by
eating it so I've heard you talk about
the ownership that some of your fans can
have over the art that you create crazy
no neat right what's the difference
between a song that no Gallagher wants
to make in a song that Noel Gallagher's
fans wanted to make
ha ha boom I mean I guess they'd want me
to make music that sounded like voices
fans they're not know what they [ __ ]
are nobody wanted jimi hendrix before he
came along
nobody wanted Oasis before we came or
nobody wanted the Sex Pistols they don't
know what they want until you give it to
him but you know I don't I don't wake up
in the morning or go to bed at night
worrying about what fans want you know
her worried about that I wouldn't have
left Oasis in the first place I still be
there picking up the checks try me
traveling separately from the rest of
the band and turning up dialing it in
like most [ __ ] rock bands you'll be
going thirty years they don't go on but
they all got the balls to leave and do
their own thing I don't care what fans
want a [ __ ]
[Music]
because anyone ever got to the end and
not sweated at all well everybody's
different so everybody will have a
different spice tolerance which is
interesting for me I'm satisfied homes
for the Spice Girls but Stone Cold Steve
Austin he was like our season 9 finale
he came in here and he was like
basically unfazed
he's a real dude you're a wrestling fan
right I do yeah I love watching it in
the 90s but my kids are into it now
enough I brought but one of them to see
when they came to London and we were
taken backstage to meet some of the
wrestlers an in walk [ __ ] Hulk Hogan
and he bends down and he says to my
little man hey buddy how are you buddy
get up for one of my little Hulkamania
it's gonna you lit one of my little
Hulkamaniacs Donovan's like yes and he
looks what I mean he said what about you
big man but you are my Hulkamaniacs and
I was like yes I am he was go ahead he
was going to hear like your daddy's a
hulkamaniac at your Halloween we will
put me a look at each other Gwen and I
remain to this day a whole command
confirmed hulkamaniac card-carrying
Hulkamania absolutely was vitamins
vitamins e of a diamonds [ __ ] hawkers do
cocaine abuse steroids go to church and
everything will be fine I lived my life
with that credo ever since thanks I'll
code and Here I am
alright this next one should you choose
brutal to bomb beyond insanity the bomb
beyond insanity
double rock top got [ __ ] gone you do
this for a living in your grimacing [ __ ]
off I'm not too tough I am not too tough
who's the greatest songwriter way made
clearly of all the instruments that
you've owned which one has the most
interesting backstory I read recently
that Johnny Marr of the Smiths gifted
you a Les Paul before you were famous
yeah and he it used to belong to Pete
Townsend its royalty that you saw Paul
well has given me guitars in the past
it's like a warrior given another
warrior a sword right
and yet Excalibur they're made this is
for heat not some madman you tell me why
I'm [ __ ] telling you is there an
album that's been released in the last
20 years that you would consider a
masterpiece
[Music]
right at this very moment it's difficult
to say that's the show because that
[ __ ] thing is mental but off the top
of my head which no nobody can see
there's a home but it is starting to
shrivel I'd say one of mine maybe who
brought the moon can you give us one
band that everyone should see before
they die
that's a band called young fathers
that's the last great band I sing live
[ __ ] amazing has anybody ever come
back for a second goal actually we've
had a couple people recently in between
seasons we've been doing these reunion
specials can we can we count on you no
not a [ __ ] chance right
that was that was dark
the bum beyond insanity you know that
was dark this next one's called burner
free
[ __ ]
I'm not even warm up
[Music]
I mean people genuinely eat the [ __ ] out
some people are crazy
some people are crazy there's making a
[ __ ] woman on a date oh wow I need now
mm-hmm mm-hmm [ __ ] now oh my god what
does it mean when people from Manchester
say that song is bobbins it means it's
not very good bobbins is not bobbins
yeah bobbins are little plastic things
that people used to sew on [ __ ] other
things can you explain the whole tea
dinner lunch thing because it's very
confusing okay up north
lunch is called dinner and dinner is
called tea and the only thing that will
give away that you live in London to a
Mancunian is the fact that you say going
for lunch
for our viewers who are probably not
familiar what can you tell us about
Manchester legend a guy called Gerald oh
well he was a DJ he wrote one of these
seminal great dance music singles of all
time called voodoo ray an absolute
pioneer without him
and I try to music in a very different
place I think did you have a favorite
teacher at st. Mark's no no they were
all [ __ ] oh yeah
[Music]
okay right I'm not putting any more on
that's fine that's fine
ah it already tastes [ __ ] already I
even got in anything why is it not burn
your stomach yet
well here we are at the end of our run
and you famously have an opinion on
everything but let me just throw a
couple subjects at you and you just tell
me the first thoughts that come to mind
okay Manchester United in the passage of
irrelevant brexit oh just a biggest load
of [ __ ] ever I think it's a stupid
backward step that the country is taking
saying that the majority of the people
democratically voted for it so they've
got to see it through now what the
politicians are trying to make it not
happen they're a [ __ ] disgrace the
politicians are not I mean most
politicians anyway are a disgrace the
ones in England have not covered
themselves in glory over the past two
years YouTube
it can be alright Khan it do we need to
see goats singing Taylor Swift songs
I don't not sure I'm not sure the world
needs that but other than that some good
stuff on there you're on there I'm on
there
we're on there I'm on there [ __ ]
being burnt to death now forever well
you know what it was not in vain no
Gallagher because now you have just
taken on the wings of death I want a
[ __ ] t-shirt and a cop with the thing
on and a picture on the wall of fame
watch us see that through I want a
[ __ ] teacher but in the meantime no
Gallagher there's nothing left to do but
roll out the red carpet for you my
friend this camera this camera this
camera let the people know what you have
gone on in your life what have I got
going on well at today I'll be going
straight to the hospital to get my
stomach pumped but I do have an EP out
which will help the proceeds will help
my recovery which is going to be [ __ ]
long you're welcome by the way I'm a
credit to the [ __ ] world Oh have I
got steam coming out my ears when they
choose a new pope no maybe even better
now then what's up spice Lords camera
guy bill here saying it's that time
again to sign up for the new hot one
subscription box that's right this
October you can be the first to get your
hands on the new hot ones season 10
heavyweight champion
the last tab xxx it really packs the
heat with chocolate X peach X mustard X
but quantities are limited so you got to
go to heat and us to eat and his teenis
calm calm come to sign up for your box
now that's right go to heating this calm
to sign up for your box now it's a real
knockout
oh this camera guy bill here saying it's
good to be camera guy bill
[Music]